let's go next why don't we go to Peter
from Allentown Peter from Allentown
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
I have a just kind of a quick question
yes
do you think the United States will ever
fully adopt the metric system
you know the best reason I read about
why the U.S will not adopt the metric
system is a combination of having to
re-educate everyone and the cost of all
the signs having to make all new signs
that it would just that that it's sort
of like it's a path dependent Monopoly
sort of situation that we're on where
we're so far in that it's always like
well it really doesn't make sense to do
it and then you're further in and then
you can say wow now it really doesn't
make sense to do it so now I don't know
I would love for the US to adopt the
metric system I really don't see it
happening
I mean I mean there was a push I
remember back when I was in elementary
school in the 70s there was this big
push they had little little cartoon
little songs kind of like Schoolhouse
Rock but with the metric system yeah and
there was a real real you know honest
push but it just there's some I don't
know what it is about the American
psyche or culture that there's such a
resistance with it they probably think
it's kind of like you know like 50
European yeah those Europeans with
everything based on tens obviously we're
gonna have you know a 5 280 foot mile
and a 12 inch foot yeah I mean it's it
is crazy no I I agree I think there is
that is a factor yeah those CIS
Europeans with their metric system of
course it's like almost the entire
planet
all right well thanks Amy that's all I
wanted today all right Peter from
Allentown thank you very much appreciate
the call